vor juni folgt das klappt jetzt
willkommen bei der neuen video ja heute
mal wieder was ganz spezielles das habe
ich letztens schon mal gemacht ist
selbst bei langen was heißt sehr gut
also schon gut bei euch angekommen und
ich hab heute eine person die bei euch
total beliebt ist dabei leider nur
hinter der kamera sagt ja und es waren
wir uns heute wie schon oben erwähnt was
ganz besonderes überlegt sie wird mir
jetzt gleich fünf weitere frauen
produkte oder produkte von frauen oder
von ihr keine ahnung die auch zum teil
in die kommentare geschrieben habt geben
oder nicht
ja das jahr hat die ich hab doch gesagt
aus den kommentaren das kannst du auch
kaufen
hast du nicht sie wird mir gleich fünf
neue frauen produkte von ihr geben
schreibt in die kommentare welche frauen
produkte ich noch testen soll dann wird
das ja vielleicht beim nächsten mal was
danke jetzt auch egal
ich würde sagen wir wollen gar nicht
eingeladen ich fange direkt mal an wenn
ihr noch bock auf den dritten teil ab
dann lasst einfach genau jetzt schon mal
daumen nach oben da und gib mir doch
einfach mal das erste produkt sind die
heute schwerer oder nicht so schwer wie
letztes mal okay dann gib mir war das
erste ja leute das erste produkt ist ein
oster ei was unten abgeschnitten wurde
das riecht eigentlich recht gut so aber
ich habe echt keine ahnung ehrlich
vielleicht zum abschminken
zum schminken so zum schminken so echtes
hüpfen und so macht schminke hier dran
und tue das da hier ein give me the next
product bei der englisch englisch
gallerin okay beim nächsten produkt
handelt es sich um das ja einfach die
macht man nicht so ins haar
wer kommt bitte da nicht drauf da jetzt
auch mal was vernünftiges besorgen
können oder die ärzte
eine bürste zum sauber macht also haben
wir dieses produkt dass es irgendwo eine
bürste steht vorjahr beauty drauf ich
würde damit jetzt vielleicht etwas
anderes machen was meinst du ich
prozedur koffer voll gut habe ich
bekommen vorjahr beauty is voll gut also
das wird mir halt dazu einfallen sonst
könnte ich auch noch weiß ich nicht
meine fingernägel saubermachen oder so
fingernägel saubermachen
keine ahnung wie soll man damit sonst
saubermachen das ist irgendwas was im
körper sauber machen muss oder irgendwie
sowas sein wofür so was bringt das dann
so weiß es nicht
hauptsache erstmal kaufen was bringt so
ein scheiß ehrlich wenn man wie so wie
soll man das denn sauber machen was ist
wenn dann im gesicht wenn man weiss
nicht wenn man sich an gekotzt hat man
dass man diese alt wirst du sauber
machen oder was
fast ganz frisch und strahlend nee danke
sonne scheint wieder empfohlen das
braucht kein mensch ehrlich auch einfach
das nächste einfach okay ja das kenne
ich das ist voller was ich mich bei
diesem produkt immer fragen das ist ja
eine wimpernzange man hat doch auch zwei
finger kummer macht es einen unterschied
ob ich das so machen oder so hier mit
reichlich mich höchstens meine wimpern
raus kommen wir zum nächsten und letzten
produkt letzten produkt und zwar klein
trommelwirbel jetzt richtig auf die
fresse den schluss aufgehoben
dankeschön gab es haben weicht so habe
ich das erinnert früher in diesem spiel
park kann man immer so sachen zusammen
bauen mit so komischen weißt du dann war
es immer die passende perfekt zusammen
dann hat man immer so was gutes gebaut
aber keine ahnung wie das ist
verkleidung
ich bin jetzt ein hirsch sieht aus wie
ein fuß also sowie 10 19
ich weiß was spaß hatte man jetzt muss
ich mal kurz meine socken ausziehen
sieht man dass ein
warum
was bringt mir das jetzt also nicht
damit aber als hilfe
ich kann mir die auto lackieren dann
würden die so aneinander kommen dann
wird der kleine szene zum beispiel weißt
du was ihr seid frauen ihr könnt euch im
gesicht so schön schminken und dann
braucht ihr für die zehn hilfe für die
ich weiß aber auch gut und wegen solcher
scheiß heute jetzt irgendeine resta von
hat bestimmt ist er millionär geworden
leute das war's mit diesem wunderschönen
wenn es euch gefallen hat dann würde ich
sagen
schreibt einfach mal in die kommentare
was was wir noch abstellen was mir noch
mal was sie noch mal für mich kaufen
sollte vielleicht beachtet ja dann auch
eure kommentare
woran ich nicht mehr glaube aber es
könnte ja irgendwann mal ein treffen im
ja ansonsten war es mit dem video
zusammen nach oben nicht vergessen und
hat rein